c'est l'un des transferts phares du
mercato radio qui s'est ouvert il ya
quelques jours le départ de stéphane
bern d'rtl si jusqu'ici l'animateur
était resté évasif sur les raisons de
son éviction rtl n'a plus envie de moi
le parisien évoque deux raisons
plausibles pour expliquer le choix de la
station tout d'abord l'émission semblait
s'essouffler mais ça n'est pas tout
selon une source anonyme chez rtl
l'animateur de s'impliquer pas trop dans
son émission la vérité c'est que
stéphane bern s'est reposé sur ses
lauriers cas elle se croyait protégé
mais plus personne ne l'est l'époque est
aux économies et le nouveau patron n'est
pas impressionné par la proximité de
l'animateur avec le couple macron voilà
qui devrait faire plaisir à stéphane
bern qu'on retrouvera à la rentrée sur
europe 1 où il animera chaque jour une
émission sur l'histoire et c'est vrai
que donc ben voilà donc stéphane bern et
julien courbet qui cartonne sur arte
photo qui a commencé son émission avec
une petite chanson à la gloire du patron
de rtl
régis ravanas et il évoque en même temps
le départ de stéphane bern regarder
julien courbet qui nous a régalés sur
rtl encore excellent jus d'un anneau
chanter avec piqué allons danser avec la
vie
le but
et si tony plus a vécu berne car lui je
crois qu'il s'en vend aux le c'est vrai
que voilà stéphane bern voilà on espère
qu'il va travailler sur europe 1 parce
que ils en ont besoin bien entendu nos
amis d'europe 1 on aime beaucoup et même
rtl veut qu'europe 1 remonte et ça
commence à aller à un petit peu joué ou
lire aussi on va pas se mentir voilà rtl
voilà ce qu'elle va être premier à
d'autres ans au 15 juillet et bien sûr
elle est déjà son plein le quart d'heure
passé mais vous savez qu'elle nous
effectivement ça nous arrange ses europe
1 seront monde parce que les gens qui
partent d'un terrien en a beaucoup qui
vont elles qui parle d'europe à y en a
beaucoup qui vont sur inter parce que la
pub mais ça c'est des discussions radio
personnes comprend alors julien c'est
génial parce que c'est vrai qu'il ose
tout et ça fait rire régis qui va
souvent dans son dans son studio etc moi
ça me fait rire c'est gilbert merci
c'est génial merci énormément en berne
je pense que c'est parce que justement
il a été très affichée avec les
maquereaux qu'on a beaucoup parlé but
pour le loto du patrimoine et oukil un
peu usant de mélange des genres qui
paient pas trop aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on l'a écartée
même si peut-être qui s'essouffle dans
l'émission moi je crois qu'ils ont
maintenant je crois que je vais vous
dire ça fait une ou moi je moi je
connais très bien et missions ses fans
puisque on était je suis je suis parti à
rtl pour aller surfer la matinale de
virgin radio et j'ai été sur cette case
là avec jean pierre foucault à l'époque
voilà et c'est vrai que la case aussi
voilà mais c'est normal n'a fait que
baisser d'année en année au niveau voilà
d'élégance case voilà donc c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que jean pierre foucault
à cette heure ci qui était même seul il
n'a jamais été égalée au niveau des
audiences adhère t elle confiant et
chanteur n'a jamais été égalé et c'est
vrai que ça a baissé tout de suite après
l'arrivée de stéphane ci restait correct
mais c'est vrai que ça fait que baisser
moi je souhaite beaucoup de bien à
stéphane bern mémoire pas dit moi
j'écoute airtel calvi après ya isabelle
qui arrive après y'a courbet qui arrive
je me régale avec julien courbet parce
qu'ils aident les gens à résoudre des
problèmes et des stéphane bern arrive
avec son équipe ça casse le rythme et je
m'en vais sur d'autres radios je ne sais
pas continuer donc je pense pas que ce
soit que les maquereaux il y avait une
histoire aussi d' horribles de cohérence
de fouiller la maison
de rigoler avec courbet l'épreuve des
gens tu étais dans la dynamique tu
voulais pas changer de radio et stéphane
bern il arrivait et je lui souhaite du
bien la tête était plombé la joie qu'ils
avaient des missions mais c'est
remplacer par un jeu je crois alors
franchement je suis désolé de vous dire
la bonne heure j'aime beaucoup
stéphane bern mais l'émission voilà
c'est un petit peu plan-plan estevan
avait besoin d'un nouveau challenge là
là là je voulais voir les réformes n'ont
rien et cartonner sur france inter ali
ben sûr parce qu'ils avaient ils étaient
un petit peu trop ppr c'est un horaire
en plus je vous dis 11h comptes dit la
radio
c'est pas non plus voilà pour les radios
donc voilà donc c'est vrai qu'à un
moment voilà il a je pense que là le
faire l'après midi ça va lui donner un
bon coup de fouet de matthieu noël rey
c'est si vrai ce que vous dites qu'à la
fin ils ont obligé la ligne 3 ou 4
dernières semaines à faire un truc
d'histoire et c'était plus intéressant
sera bien sûr je te dis mais l'histoire
selon moi je suis un féru d'histoire
moissac